can you all hear me okay all right oh
cool so my name is Nora Casper again I'm
here from Washington DC and my talk is
called empathy as a service supporting
mental health in the tech workplace and
I'm actually gonna save most of my self
introduction for the second part of the
talk I first want to cover some of the
statistics and definitions and things
like that related to mental health and
mental illness to make sure that we're
all kind of on the same page here
then I'll go more into my own story and
why this is so important to me but then
the bulk of the talk is really going to
be focused on things all of us can do in
our own workplaces and our own lives
common sense action-oriented things that
we can all put into action to support
mental health better and then there's a
short section on the end on things that
we all have to do together or
essentially it's it's more difficult and
more aspirational but still needs to be
done so first what are we talking about
so if there's anything that I want you
all to walk away from here with it's
this statistic it's that one in five
adults are living with mental illness at
any given time that's a huge number in
fact it basically means that mental
illness is one of the most prevalent
chronic health conditions but if you
think about it we really don't ever talk
about it
and to be clear when I say mental
illness I'm talking about any one of
these when some of these may you may
have heard of before some of these you
may not have another thing is there's
this phenomenon called comorbidities
which means that when you have one of
these illnesses it also often makes you
more prone to develop another illness so
for example depression and anxiety often
go together depression and substance use
disorder ADHD and anxiety often go
together etc to that I wanted to kind of
point out specifically our autism
spectrum disorders and burnout so autism
spectrum disorders are kind of part of
this bigger umbrella term of mental
disorders but they're often accompanied
by other things like learning
disabilities sometimes also physical
health issues and so they often require
their own kinds of treatments and
interventions etc so organizations that
focus on activism around mental health
often focus either on some of the rest
of these like depression and
xiety or autism spectrum disorder
specifically just because there was
required more specialized treatments and
so I'm not going to talk too much about
autism spectrum disorders today because
the organization that I work with is
focused more on the other kinds of
mental illnesses but there's still quite
a bit of overlap and a lot of what I'm
going to talk about is still relevant
for autism as well and then obviously
we're gonna be talking a lot about the
workplace so I wanted to call out the
idea of burnout especially in the United
States were where I come from when the
idea of burnout was introduced in the
1970s there was quite a bit of pushback
people said you know that's silly the
whole idea that you can get sick from
working too much so I did some research
and looked into you know where are we at
in 2018 what does the research nowadays
say and most psychologists actually
agreed that burnout is actually
depression they did a lot of studies
that show that at the end of the day on
when they control for all kinds of
factors the symptoms are essentially the
same but it is essentially depression
with a very specific cause which is
prolonged stress from working too much
so it's fine to continue to refer to it
as burnout we don't have to say
depression necessarily but I just
figured since we're gonna be talking
about the workplace that's an important
thing to know about but a big problem
with mental illness is that there's
often kind of preconceived notions about
what that means so if I say mental
illness to a random stranger chances are
they're gonna think of something like
schizophrenia but in fact depression in
particular is one of the most common
mental illnesses and it's at least 13
times more prevalent than schizophrenia
another big problem is there's lots of
misunderstandings about things like the
symptoms of depression so we often
associated with things like feelings of
sadness emptiness loss of interest and
pleasure in normal activities and
tiredness and lack of energy but there's
actually a whole spectrum of emotions
that's possible when you're suffering
from depression so it can also include
things like angry outbursts and
irritability any kind of sleep
disturbances which can be insomnia or
sleeping too much any kind of changes in
appetite and anxiety agitation or
restlessness and in fact one thing that
they're finding recently is that when
women experience depression they're much
more likely to experience the
of sadness and emptiness and loss of
interest and pleasure in normal
activities whereas one men experience
depression they're much more likely to
have symptoms like the angry outbursts
and irritability and anxiety agitation
and restlessness and so because we don't
often associate those with depression
men are more likely to not even realize
that they're suffering from depression
another problem with the depression in
particular is that we tend to shame
people for feeling this way and a lot of
people with depression or often say that
they'll hear things like I can't believe
you are feeling sad when kids in Africa
are starving and there's a report to
this that does its rounds on the
internet every couple of months that I
think is really powerful that says
telling someone not to be sad because
others have it worse is like telling
people they can't be happy because
others have it better another really
great illustration of the stigma against
mental illness is from this webcomic
called robot hugs
it's called helpful advice and the
subtitle here is a physical illness were
treated like mental illness so just in
case you can't read the captions I'll
read them out loud on the left it says I
get that you have food poisoning at all
but you have to at least make an effort
on the right you just need to change
your frame of mind then you'll feel
better
have you tried you know not having the
flu I don't think it's healthy that you
have to take medication every day just
to feel normal
don't you worry that it's changing you
from who you really are it's like you're
not even trying
and while lying in bed obviously isn't
helping you you need to try something
else and all of the stigma and all of
the shame is a really big problem
because even in high-income countries
like Iceland and the United States
anywhere from thirty five to fifty
percent of people with mental disorders
do not receive any kind of treatment and
that's a problem because for example
with severe depression 15 percent of
people end up dying by suicide so when
the stakes are so high you would think
that people would speak up but the
reason they don't is because of fear
things like fear of dismissal fear of
being taken out of promotion
consideration fear of being taken off
high value projects and contracts fear
of reduced hours for hourly workers fear
of being asked to take unpaid medical
leave and just in general of fear being
treated differently and another problem
in the workplace and
in western countries is that we have
this idea of you should leave your
personal life at home when you come to
work but that doesn't work when you have
mental illness you can't just shut off
your depression for eight hours a day
come to work work productively and then
come home and deal with your depression
again for better or worse it's a part of
you and we have to do a better job of
accepting people as their whole selves
so now I'll talk a little bit about
myself and why I speak up about this and
I legitimately get asked this question a
lot because I am a software engineer
just like all of you I'm not a mental
health professional I've taken one
psychology class in my entire life I
actually went to art school twice I also
identify as mentally healthy and that
makes me a little bit unusual because
there are others who speak up about this
topic and they usually do so because
they are living with mental illness
themselves but the reason why I speak up
is because of her this is my best friend
me she and I met about seven years ago
when we were both living in New York
City at the time she had just moved
there from Seattle she had studied
biochemical and her parents really
wanted her to go to medical school but
she was interested in designing
technology and she convinced this
company to give her a web development
fellowship where she could basically
learn the tools of the job on the job so
she she and I headed off immediately he
became really close and she was doing
really well at work and after about a
year and a half in New York City she
realized that the next best thing that
she could do to advance her career was
to move to San Francisco and work at a
startup so obviously I was sad to see
her go but thanks to modern technology
we kept in touch and still talked all
the time but when she got to San
Francisco her imposter syndrome started
becoming more of a problem coming from
kind of a non-traditional background in
tech and that was an issue because she
had been living most of her adult life
with bipolar disorder but we thought she
was doing okay we thought she was doing
better and so it kind of took us all by
surprise when September 2 in September
2016 she took her own life so all of
this is still really difficult for me to
talk about so if you really want to know
more about this I wrote a very long blog
post about this on medium last year
but after all of this happened and after
I had a little bit of time to kind of
process this I realized that I really
wanted to turn my grief into action I
didn't want to just sit back and and
just continue to let this happen to
people like me and so I started
volunteering with this organization
called open sourcing mental illness
which was founded by this guy in the
right ed Fink ler he had been part of
the PHP conference speaker circuit for a
number of years and about four or five
years ago he started speaking up about
his own experiences living with
generalized anxiety disorder in ADHD and
how that affected his life as a
developer and his career in tech and his
talk actually resonated with a lot of
people and so they finally decided to
form a whole organization around it
which is now an official 501 C 3
non-profit in the United States called
open sourcing mental illness or Oh SMI
and so awareness campaigns are a really
big part of what OS mi does but we also
have a research arm we put out the
survey every year called the mental
health and tech survey where we
basically ask any and all of you who are
working in the tech industry to answer
these questions that allow us to gauge
what the attitudes are towards mental
health in tech and every year will
change up the questions a little bit but
there's always kind of a variation of
this one question which shows us that we
still have a lot of work to do it's
really to two variations of one question
it's do you think that discussing a
physical health issue with your employer
would have negative consequences and do
you think that discussing a mental
health issue with your employer would
have negative consequences and so you
can see on the left for the physical
health question the nose make up pretty
much 75% of all the responses but on the
right for the mental health questions
the esses and the maybes make up about
two-thirds of the pie that's a pretty
striking difference and shows that we
still have a lot of work to you so I've
been involved with OMI for almost a year
and a half now and I would say that my
biggest contribution in this community
as someone who is mentally healthy has
been to sit back and listen to people
like IDI tell their stories and to try
to empathize and think about what people
like me can do and there have been times
when that's legit illegitimate lis been
tough but there was a quote that Ed used
in one of his talks that I thought was
really powerful and that really kind of
opened my eye
- what how I really needed to approach
this which was I could do so many
awesome things
if only my own head didn't get in the
way and the first time I heard this I
just really stopped me in my tracks
because I realized my ability to do my
job as a software engineer rests solely
in my head I don't need muscles I'm not
a construction worker I really just get
to go to work every day and take for
granted that my brain is gonna do
everything that I tell it to do but
people like Edie can't do that and so I
started kind of thinking about you know
what if what if this is how I felt as I
went about my day how would that change
things or how much would my environment
have to change in order to accommodate
this better and so that kind of led me
down this path of thinking more about
what can the rest of us do and so they
got started with that I started just
kind of characterizing the tech industry
and thinking about what some of the the
unique kind of challenges and
characteristics are so things like the
work is challenging is stressful
our jobs are highly collaborative many
of us have relocated for a job most of
us work remotely at least part of the
time we're often expected to be
available outside work hours
someone needs to fix things when they
break overnight and there is a very hon
fit heavy emphasis on drinking culture
and so I started thinking about
relocation in particular because as I
had mentioned my friend knee had
relocated twice in order to work in tech
and one of her friends mentioned at the
funeral that she had mentioned to them
recently that she kind of regretted not
going back to Seattle where her family
was and so I was thinking about this a
lot and thinking you know it can't be
all bad there have to be legit
legitimate reasons why we really
relocate um so I just kind of started
approaching it from that angle of
thinking about like what are the pros
and cons so on the positive side it
makes that much easier to feel like
you're a part of the team and helping
towards the mission if you're on site
with everyone else or in these case it
can bring you closer to a community of
practitioners in your field compared to
where you currently are but on the
negative side it takes someone away from
the existing support structures that
they've already built up like the
therapists that they're seeing or the
friend whose house they can come to at
1:00 in the morning because you really
just need to have a good cry also moving
is generally always going to be
stressful and making new friends as an
adult is surprisingly hard
so I started thinking about solutions
and I promise I'm going to focus more on
pragmatic ones but this one this first
one is a little bit more aspirational
but I very strongly believe that as a
community we need to stop saying that
the best way to succeed in tech is to
relocate to Silicon Valley that may have
been true about 15 years ago but I think
things like remote work have come a long
way we need to become a lot more
accepting of alternative choices if you
are a manager take another look at your
hiring practices and see whether hiring
remote first employees is an option and
finally if that's not an option if
someone does have to relocate to join
your company make sure that you focus on
helping introduce that colleagues to
organizations and events in the area
after hours essentially ways for them to
start building up those support
structures again so I mentioned remote
work as a positive and I think in
general it is very positive for mental
health and people struggling with mental
illness for example it often leads to
more flexible hours and that in turn is
good because it makes it much easier to
attend daytime therapy appointments it
turns out that therapists like to work
9:00 to 5:00 Monday to Friday like all
of the rest of us so if you want to
start seeing a therapist you're going to
have to do that during the work day and
so a lot of people that I've talked to
have said working from home on the day
that you see your therapist it's just so
much easier because you can just kind of
duck out with everyone knowing that
you're going somewhere else for similar
reasons that can also make it easier to
stick to medication regimens it's often
easier to take breaks and in general
it's more quiet and peaceful than being
in the office but on the negative side
there is a sense of isolation that sits
in if especially if you're working from
home a hundred percent of the time and
I've had a couple of friends recently
who I've started working completely
remotely and it's always been
interesting because the first couple
months of this kind there's this kind of
honeymoon phase where like they're like
this is amazing how why have I not been
doing this my entire life I love working
in my pajamas this is great but then
after about two months that honeymoon
phase kind of wears off and the sense of
isolation sets in and they start
complaining that they're feeling lonely
they're missing the watercooler
conversations the connections with their
their colleagues etc and along those
Lions in general working remotely can
make it harder to build strong
relationships with your co-workers
especially if you're the only one who's
remote and everyone else is on site
together and even if you're not
struggling with mental illness but you
just want to be a good supportive
colleague it can make it harder to tell
if everyone's doing okay if you're
mostly just communicating by slack and
the occasional Skype call and it can
also make it challenging to maintain a
work-life balance especially if you're
truly working from home and your home is
your office I've heard from a lot of
people that they just have difficulty
saying okay it's five o'clock I'm not
gonna respond to work emails and slack
anymore so some of the solutions
co-working spaces I think are excellent
and really undervalued and I think one
of the biggest barriers to people trying
it out is that there is often an
initiation fee or a monthly fee that you
have to pay so a good solution for this
is to have the company at the very least
pay for the first month so that that
person will be more likely to try it and
see if it's for them and to be clear
this is not something that you have to
do every day I've heard from a lot of
people that even if they just go into a
co-working space once a week it's still
helpful and makes them feel less
isolated
also make sure you occasionally fly in
remote employees or hold company-wide
off sites to make sure like everyone
feels like they're part of the team and
they're getting a chance to bond
and finally there's just so much
research happening around remote work
culture and how to make it better that
there's so many resources that you can
leverage there's whole conferences
around this now so just look into kind
of what the latest kind of state of the
art around remote work is try some
things with your team if you find that
you're still struggling and see if it
works for you and if not try something
else there's there's just so many things
to try so the first time that I was
going to give this talk one of the
things that surprised me the most was
someone came back and said so what about
open-plan offices what are you planning
to say about that and I actually had not
planned on saying anything at all but so
I figured okay this is a good question
so let me do some research so on the
positive side they are more conducive to
collaboration kratom creative
problem-solving between multiple
employees people having more organic
conversations that lead to solutions
that no one had thought of on their own
etc I used to think that that's why
everyone did it but it turns out that
it's actually
because it's just easier to construct
offices that way because of things like
building fire codes it could also can
increase a sense of team unity or
camaraderie but I really want to
emphasize the can here because if
there's already friction on the team
then it can actually increase it
resentment instead but on the negative
side the number one complaint about
open-plan offices is the noise and how
it reduces productivity from a mental
health perspective I think the biggest
concern is the lack of privacy when I
talked about remote work before when I
said you know working from home makes it
easier to duck out in the afternoon for
your like therapy appointments this is
kind of the exact opposite right you're
working very closely with everyone so if
you need to duck out for the therapy
appointment everyone's going to know
about it people also have cited an
increased sense of stress and there's
also increased peer pressure and this is
a problem for mental health because I
think it's quite off it happens quite
often to us as developers where
sometimes we just get stuck and we
realized that the absolute best thing
that we can do for ourselves is just to
take a break for maybe like 20 minutes
go take a walk around the block do
something completely different but what
often happens in open-plan offices is
you look around and everyone else has
bent over their desks and they look
productive and what happens in that case
is you talk yourself out of taking that
break and that's actually the worst
possible thing that you can do for
yourself in that moment and finally
open-plan offices are are also highly
conducive to the spread of physical
disease like the cold the flu etc so
again I'm focusing on pragmatic
solutions so I love to come up here and
say we should not have open-plan offices
anymore but I think the vast majority of
us are not in the position to make that
call so then the next easiest and best
thing to do is to make sure that
everyone is allowed to work remotely or
if they are already maybe increase the
number of days per week or per month
when they can do so also regardless
always urge your employees to work from
home when they're sick don't have them
bring the cold or the flu into the
office maybe try setting aside small
meeting spaces for quiet work I work in
a pretty big office and I think for
those of us with big offices one thing
that happens is there's always that one
conference room that's actually too
small to have a productive meeting in so
maybe just that
one aside for people to check out for
like an hour if they realize that they
just need a bit of quiet time in the
afternoon where they can get some
productive work done also have the
company provide noise cancelling
headphones this is often the easiest
solution that everyone turns to first
and it does work pretty effectively and
then finally encourage employees to
decorate their workspace and this might
sound on the surface like it has nothing
to do with improving offices and
productivity at all but the research has
actually says the out the opposite
there was a 2014 study done in Sweden
where they tested out different office
configurations and they had their the
people who worked in them basically rate
how these office configurations made
them feel and the one that was rated the
worst interestingly enough especially
among men was the open-plan Flex office
which is an open plan office where no
one has their own desk and there was a
2010 study done that was done in the UK
where they compared people who had
decorated and personalized the workspace
and people who hadn't and they found
that the people who had decorated their
workspaces were actually one-third more
productive so as silly as it sounds
these life hacks actually work and then
alcohol tech events so this is kind of a
controversial one but let me go through
the kind of positives and negatives
first so one or two drinks can make it
easier for some introverts and those
with social anxiety to socialize with
their peers and I'm guilty of this
myself and the next one is a bit of a
positive negative but if you don't offer
alcohol than those who want to drink
will go to a bar instead of staying to
mingle with others at your event so
conferences like this one that's often
the reason why they say they have
alcohol they want everyone to stay here
and and kind of socialize and network
because that's the whole point of why
we're doing we're having conferences
like this but on the negative side it
makes non-drinkers feel unwelcome in
general and if you're a recovering
alcoholic then you're definitely going
to feel threatened by the kind of event
where alcohol is flowing three flowing
freely and to be clear alcoholism is
substance use disorder is a mental
illness and in general Frio alcoholic
drinking culture are so pervasive that
they're probably more functioning
alcoholics and tectum were even aware of
so some of the solutions i personnaly a
mountain of dual saying no one should
ever have alcohol attack events again I
think there's like intermediate steps
that we can try in the meantime one
thing that some places have tried that
actually work pretty well are for
example making sure that you always
offer nice alternatives things like the
fancy sodas that come in the glass
bottles or even mocktails to make sure
that nong drinkers feel like they're
included I've heard from several non
drinkers that often the biggest insult
to them is to get to the after-party and
everyone else is getting like customized
cocktails and they just get some like
lukewarm sodas where they have to like
fill their own ice so make sure that
you're treating everyone equally also
put a limit on the number of free drinks
that you give out use some kind of
ticket or token system and people
usually do this for budget reasons but
it ends up working out well for health
reasons as well because the way it
usually works is you'll get like two
free drink tickets and after that it
turns into a cash bar but what that
leads to is someone will have their two
free drinks and they'll be thinking
about do I want to take out my wallet to
pay for that third drink and what often
happens then is that they'll realize
actually I have a pretty good buzz going
and maybe I don't need that third drink
so then they're not getting drunk and
you don't have to deal with those kinds
of health consequences also always make
sure that you have activities other than
drinking it turns out that there's a
pretty big overlap between developers
and people who like playing board games
so you would think that more tech events
would have things like a board game
night if you're having a recurring
series of events like a weekly company
happy hour or a monthly meetup maybe
just try alternating dry and written on
dry events so don't cut out the alcohol
completely but you don't have to do it
every single time
and then finally add workplace wellness
programs on substance abuse I think
these are the kind of thing where most
of us will roll our eyes at them when
they happen but research has shown that
they're actually relatively effective it
turns out that most of us just need that
periodic reminder that there are serious
consequences to drinking too much and
that reinforcement is just very helpful
for managers and tech leads and senior
devs I think overall the biggest piece
of advice is just to lead by example on
things like not micromanaging leaving
the office on
I'm taking regular vacations yourself
not sending our answering emails at 2:00
a.m. if possible being receptive to
feedback on your own performance in
addition giving people feedback on their
performance and being a good listener
and really the only thing that I would
say that's kind of unique to to mental
health is that you should try to be more
open to talking about your own health or
mental health or maybe something that
happened in your family because it turns
out that really your number-one goal
should be for your employees or your
reports to come to you and say hey look
I'm struggling with this issue I might
need an accommodation that sort of thing
but people are not gonna do that if you
haven't been a little bit more
vulnerable and open about some things
that you yourself have struggled with so
it sounds really counterintuitive I feel
like most of us by the time that we get
to like that senior level we feel like
we should be like completely invincible
but actually being vulnerable is
probably one of your best assets some
other action items for managers make
sure your employees understand their
benefits and what mental health
treatments are covered revisit your
hiring practices with an eye to mental
illness and neurodiversity and I'll talk
more about neurodiversity in a minute
make sure employees feel valued in our
own projects that they find fulfilling
and empowering and this might sound on
the surface like it has nothing at all
to do with mental health but I would say
like this is the single biggest takeaway
for me and my time with osm eye and
listening to other people tell their
stories is that I've noticed a trend
that when people are saying like I feel
like my depression is starting to come
back I feel like my symptoms are getting
worse it's often accompanied by change
at work at work so they got put on a
different project they feel like they're
not getting as many opportunities to
give feedback or make changes in the
process the management is just not being
transparent about why they're doing this
etc etc so making sure people that
making sure people feel valued and are
feeling fulfilled is actually really
important for mental wellness as well
get the oh so my handbooks they are on
the OS and my website but you can also
get them directly from lean pub two of
them deal with the Americans with
Disabilities Act so they're probably
only relevant if you're in the US but
the third one talks about how to start a
mental wellness program in your
workplace and that would be a great one
for everyone here to check
and then finally consider offering the
Mental Health First Aid training so
Mental Health First Aid is this
international program that was started
in Australia and is available in all of
these countries in Europe the US and
Canada I believe in India and Nepal as
well it's either 8 hours or 12 hours and
the whole focus of it is to basically
teach you how to respond if you
encounter someone having a mental health
crisis and I've heard from many people
that they they found it very useful as a
sort of empathy training essentially as
well so if you're trying to find sort of
the most effective way to really truly
get everyone to to respond to mental
health better in your company this is
probably the best thing that you can do
and can sometimes be challenging to
actually attend the training there
they're often kind of limited and where
and when they're given if you're based
in Iceland obviously it's not even one
of the countries on the list but what
you can do is actually bring in a
trainer to give the training on-site and
that's a great way it's often even
cheaper than just having one person
attend the training by themselves so
that's a great way to make sure that all
of your employees get trained or
everyone on the management team got
trained etc so finally I'll spend just a
couple of minutes talking about the
stuff that we all have to do together
where everyone has to do their part the
first really big thing is making sure
that we're always supporting
marginalized people in the tech industry
and this is important because chronic
harassment bullying and microaggressions
can lead to depression exacerbate eating
disorders and cause or worsen
other mental illnesses and people are
often surprised when I mentioned eating
disorders in the context of tech they're
like well we're not models we're not
actresses how why does it matter how you
look but it turns out that even in tech
women are still judged by their
appearance in sort of the Silicon Valley
startup culture in particular I've heard
a lot of stories about women being told
things like oh you only got this
interview because you're pretty and so
if you're already suffering with issues
of body image and eating disorders this
is just gonna make it worse and in
general people from marginalized groups
often feel like they have to over
perform because there's this whole myth
of the bar having to be lowered in order
to allow them into tech in the first
place
and so that over-performing leads to
increased stress and a much greater
likelihood of burnout we also need to
fully embrace neuro diversity so neuro
diversity is this idea that mental
disorders like ADHD and autism in
particular are the result of natural
variations of the human genome they said
that people with these kinds of
differences do not need to be cured they
need help and accommodation instead so
to be clear the strongest proponents of
neuro diversity say that we should
actually stop looking for a cure for
autism altogether I think that's a
little bit controversial and I think
it's probably worth it to keep looking
for a cure for autism but I also
recognize that even if we do find a cure
it's probably only going to help the
people who aren't born yet
chances are it's not going to help
anyone who is living with autism right
now which means there are multiple
generations of people with autism who
deserve to live healthy happy productive
lives and be contributing members to
society and it's in our own interest as
well because some of our greatest
inventions are treated to people with
atypical neurology at Sinclair himself
has this quote he likes to use in his
talks where he says mental illness gives
me super powers he talks about how his
ADHD in particular allows him to make
connections faster than a lot of other
people and understand whole systems see
solutions that they hadn't thought of
before
and there was this article in the
Harvard Business Review from last May
called neurodiversity as a competitive
advantage where they actually found the
same thing they found that people with
autism who are working at companies like
IBM and hewlett-packard were actually
incredibly productive thinking of
solutions no what a thought of etc and
the biggest barrier was actually
bringing them into the companies in the
first place they had to essentially
change up their interview process to
allow these people to enter these kinds
of companies and so finally some of the
things we can only change as a culture
the whole idea of working ourselves to
death the over emphasis on hard work and
stigma against vacation and things like
the best programmers always code on the
holidays that kind of idea the need to
always be available by phone or email
I go to Iceland to speak at a conference
like this and I always feel pressured to
tell everyone how to reach me in case of
an emergency
and that shouldn't need to be the case
the peer pressure caused by social media
there have been some studies done
recently about Facebook in particular
and they found that people suffering
from depression struggle with using
Facebook because everyone just posts
about the good things that happen in
their lives and so seeing everyone else
seemingly happy with their weddings and
their babies that cetera just makes them
feel worse and even more down on
themselves I mentioned this before but
the belief that you must be in Silicon
Valley to succeed I don't think that's
true and 2018 anymore
the stigma against talking about our
feelings and finally the idea that
engineers don't have empathy and this
was kind of a new thing for me maybe
because I went to art school but I was
talking to a woman who had started her
own business and she was saying that she
brought in this consultant who said you
can never use the word empathy around
your end engineers because they all
believe that they don't have it and so
that was incredibly strange to me
because empathy is something that we all
have the capacity for we just have to
choose to exercise it and there was a
quote that the same woman used in a talk
that she gave that I thought was really
powerful that was empathy is the
antidote to shame and she actually
mentioned this in the context of the
shame and blame culture of tech but I
think it's very true for mental illness
as well where the shame here really is
the stigma against mental illness and so
empathy is the antidote and that all
brings me back to you the title of my
talk empathy as a service
hopefully you figured out by now that
this is kind of in jest there is no app
for this
we can't deploy it to the cloud we can't
automate it away this is something that
we all have the capacity for and we have
to choose to exercise it as a service to
each other and if you're struggling with
how to do this I just bring you back to
the quote from Ed's talk that really
helped me which was I could do so many
awesome things if only my own head
didn't get in the way and so I have a
list of resources that will be in my
slides I'm not going to go through these
but feel free to ask me if you want to
know more about what any of these are
for and feel free to reach out any time
with thoughts questions etc I mean I
always told people like even if like six
months from now you're like man I really
want to talk about this my proverbial
door is always open so please come talk
to me and then finally before I forget I
do have os and my stickers so I'll come
talk to me afterwards if you want one of
those
so thank you very much
[Applause]